[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola muchas gracias un placer estar aquí
en este foro pues con todos ustedes para
hablar de lo que hacemos en cuanto a
innovación para mí es un gusto de verdad
hablar de un ejercicio tan noble como el
que hacemos y que ahorita les voy a
detallar me voy a sentir muy contento de
que por lo menos al final por lo menos
una persona al pse la mano para la
pregunta que les voy a hacer mi nombre
es luis armando grabó soy ingeniero en
biónica egresado del instituto
politécnico nacional
y soy fundador y director de la empresa
propio knicks
tenía 18 años estudiaba medicina cuando
entré a un quirófano
como ayudante de del área me tocó
participar en una amputación muy trágica
llegó un chico de su edad 20 21 años con
los brazos carbonizados
venía de electrocutarse no pudimos hacer
nada después de las valoraciones
terminamos amputándole los dos brazos y
una pierna
no sé si ustedes en algún momento se han
imaginado perder siquiera una falange de
un dedo
y quiero que hagamos rápidamente un
ejercicio me van a hacer favor todas las
personas que traigan zapatos de agujetas
de sabor tomar una agujeta y tratarla
debo tomar con una sola mano vamos a
hacerlo por favor
sin hacer trampa un minutito
a ver si lo logran hacer
esta situación es sin duda una
parte una pequeña parte de el día a día
de muchísimas personas que pierden
a veces un brazo trágicamente a veces
dos de esos brazos no es sencillo se
fijan pero esto este pequeño ejercicio
nos da para pensar y para valorar la
grandiosa oportunidad que tenemos al
estar completos
bien
este es un ejemplo de una amputación
evidentemente de un dedo pero así como
vemos el caso hay casos más superiores
de una pérdida de mano un brazo casi
completo
la siguiente por favor estas son las
opciones de prótesis la prótesis
mecánica una prótesis cosmética lo que
nosotros hemos hecho es desarrollar una
tecnología funcional
dónde
el objetivo claro ha sido desarrollar
algo que pueda ser adaptable para todos
los niveles de amputación e inclusive
ante la pérdida de todos los miembros
estas son las áreas de ingeniería que se
han tenido que conjugar para sacar
adelante este proyecto le estoy hablando
de la parte mecánica donde es modular
la tecnología esa es la parte
electrónica
donde también hemos tenido que hacer uso
de mucha mucha creatividad de innovación
ha entrado también a asistirnos la parte
de software
para calibrar inalámbricamente la
prótesis con los parámetros de cada
persona y por último hemos innovado
también en la incorporación de baterías
que también hemos de ser desarrollado al
interior de la empresa
para proporcionarle la capacidad
a cada paciente debe contar con plena
portabilidad de los equipos
y
que esto
a fin de cuentas les regrese a ellos la
posibilidad de ser independientes
hemos pasado también con él por el tema
legal de protección intelectual de este
trabajo contamos con algunas patentes
tenemos una certificación eléctrica y
este es un pequeño vídeo de una prótesis
funcional de dedo para ellos
este es un vídeo donde podemos ver a
este paciente cargando un objeto
bastante pesado perdió sus dos brazos en
un accidente mecánico
y el ahí relata lo que ha pasado en
cuanto a
el tema de esa tensión en información
desatención en rehabilitación
física y psicológica
y ahí nos está relatando cómo es que las
prótesis le han cambiado la vida para
darle mejor calidad independencia y a la
vez seguridad porque con esto él como
pueden ver ya puede trabajar
llegó a cotizar prótesis en el
extranjero inalcanzables en precio pero
gracias a esta tecnología desarrollada
en mexico 100% mexicano el trabajo
el como otros 250 pacientes han podido
contar con rehabilitación a veces me
preguntan que si ese movimiento de
rotación es para dar placer pero no es
para que ellos puedan tener otro grado
de libertad y puedan
puedes tomar los objetos y ponerlos o
posicionar los de una manera pues
diferente
e
definitivamente yo he aprendido
y muchas lecciones de estas valiosas
personas
todos ellos
evidentemente son diferentes tienen
distintas edades distintas
capacidades
diferentes sueños pero a la vez me he
dado cuenta que son iguales porque
logran sobrevivir a la discriminación
sobrevivirá al señalamiento sobrevivía a
la burla
esto es evidentemente
son lecciones que uno que está completo
tiene que aprender forzosamente de ello
y tenemos que aportar tenemos que
aprovechar la
la oportunidad de poder ver de poder
oler de poder oír de poder tocar de
poder desplazarnos muchas gentes allá
afuera no lo pueden hacer
no tienen las condiciones
que nosotros tenemos de vida
hay personas postradas en una cama que
no pueden ni siquiera acercarse un vaso
de agua a la boca
y como aportamos
innovando
es falso que la innovación esté ligada a
forzosamente a un tema tecnológico se
puede innovar en cualquier área
y la innovación queridos amigos comienza
con la educación
méxico es la cuna de la creatividad y el
ingenio lo dicen por ahí
yo creo que es un culto que debemos de
de promover desde la infancia
para encauzar esa creatividad ese
ingenio para cosas provechosas
porque se pueden hacer grandes cosas en
méxico y este recorrido fast track que
hice de lo que hemos hecho en la empresa
no es nada en comparación con lo que yo
les podría platicar que hemos logrado en
10 años
donde hemos seguido la fórmula del
doctor de
cuál es la fórmula del doctor d
la primera vez es determinación
la r es resiliencia
y la tercera vez es disciplina
no hay más esa es la fórmula para
alcanzar objetivos porque sueños hay
muchos y qué bueno que uno sueñe
de ahí nacen o han nacido las grandes
innovaciones las grandes creaciones de
la humanidad desde una idea desde un
sueño
pero si uno no tiene metas solamente son
sueños
entonces
yo digo que hay
sueños como los géneros
d
películas
hay sueños de risa
hay sueños de comedia
pero también hay sueños de acción
y estos son los que emprenden las
personas valientes que hacen transformar
realidades
problemáticas en realidades exitosas o
venturosas
llevo siete minutos hablando
podido ver de derecha a izquierda y no
logró apreciar alguna persona que le
falte un brazo una pierna
y qué bueno
si lo les faltara este brazo esta pierna
o los dos brazos o las dos piernas la
buena noticia es que hay prótesis
pero si la amputación la tuviera su
espíritu me disculpo por adelantado
no importa cuan avanzada esté la
tecnología y la ciencia no va a haber
prótesis para eso
y como nos damos cuenta de un espíritu
amputado en los jóvenes que desperdician
todo el potencial
lo derrotan viven el día al día sin
ningún plan
sin ningún propósito
cuando es precisamente ese propósito el
que hay que encontrar
para
si dios nos da la bendición de tener una
pasión por ese propósito pues ya la
hicimos porque nunca hay que trabajar
el ejercicio de esa profesión o de ese
empleo o de ese oficio va a ser un
placer realizar no lo vamos a sentir
como un trabajo y para nosotros la
atención de todas estas personas que
sufren
podemos ver que pueden otra vez
abrir una llave de agua ir al baño y
hacer sus necesidades por ellos mismos
comer independientemente para nosotros
es un placer inmenso
y cada minuto de esos
más de 13 años invertidos en desarrollar
esta tecnología han valido la pena
entonces
yo los invito a que hoy en día
este día perdón reflexionemos
sobre lo que estamos haciendo
y emprendamos
el mejor el 1er
mejor momento para emprender fue ayer
ya pasó ya no lo podemos recuperar
la buena noticia que les tengo
el mejor segundo momento para emprender
es hoy saliendo de esta conferencia
entonces yo les dije que les iba hacer
una pregunta
al término de la plática
por favor alce la mano quien después de
esta plática va a considerar emprender
muchas gracias el aplauso es para
ustedes
[Aplausos]